welcome to hannity an explosive new
report on the biden family's corrupt
business deals this time actually
involving the communist party of china
plus we have more painful evidence
tonight that pennsylvania's trust fund
brat in a hoodie that never worked a day
in his life john fetterman is not fit to
serve and in the state of new york
believe it or not gubernatorial
candidate lee zeldin is going to join us
with more on the state's insane zero
bail
laws that are now putting everybody in
the state in danger and believe it or
not i know you might not there is a
chance a republican can actually win the
governorship in a blue state like new
york we'll tell you why but we begin
with a new record for the biden
administration this year i guess it's
time to celebrate if you're pro-open
borders because for the first time in
u.s history we have now reported over 2
million illegal immigrant crossings at
our southern border breaking by the way
last year's record high of 1.7 million
in other words after vowing to address
the root causes of mass illegal
immigration well and appointing as vice
president as borders are the crisis has
become even worse than you can believe
now apparently kamala's only trip to the
southern border which really wasn't
where things were happening just a quick
trip through el paso just last year that
truly was not enough to put this in
perspective more illegal immigrants are
now pouring across this border then at
the time of this video take a look at
that video remember that video now that
shows thousands in these makeshift camps
under a bridge in del rio maybe martha's
vineyard could set up a few areas in in
that beautiful island for people that
need help they're so open minded and
they believe in sanctuary status and
they have a sign all over the place that
says we welcome immigrants but anyway
now biden is dispersing newly arriving
illegal immigrants all over the country
he's been doing this for a year and a
half 2 a.m 3 a.m 4 00 a.m in the morning
secret flight secret bus rides uh or as
jen saki used to call them early morning
flights while at the same time refusing
to even admit that we have a problem now
joe seems to think that he's owed some
kind of mulligan because this latest
wave of illegals they're coming from
venezuela and not mexico this is what
joe said
on the border why is the border more
overwhelmed under your watch mr
president because there are three
countries that are never happy there are
fewer
fewer immigrants coming from central
america and from mexico
it's a totally different circumstance
totally different wide open borders
they're still getting in reports now
from breitbart saying that venezuela is
literally empty emptying their prison
population and sending them to joe
biden's wide open borders now biden is
always more than happy to provide
excuses but here's what he will not tell
you this year alone another record 78
individuals on the fbi's terror
screening database were apprehended at
our southern border that is triple the
previous record and meanwhile record
fentanyl seizures at the border they
continue to spike fentanyl is now the
number one killer of young americans
claiming a new victim
every five minutes a record number of
migrants crossing the border are also
dying they are drowning in the rio
grande every single week some get lost
in the desert and die from thirst and
heat exhaustion others are killed by
human traffickers and some of the
cartels there are also large numbers of
reported rapes including young children
in one rural texas border county the
local funeral home has been operating at
triple their capacity stacking bodies on
top of bodies and freezers housing
others in a storage facility that was
once used for covert treatments this
facility typically performs 300 funerals
a year but it is now receiving up to 20
dead illegal immigrants every single
week this is now a real humanitarian
crisis look at your screen the situation
is so bad that maverick county they're
now burying many of these migrants in
graves mark you can see right there with
pvc pipes but none of america's virtuous
and compassionate uh democrats really
seem to care because it's not in their
backyard they only care about the people
that went to martha's vineyard instead
they're furious the governor desantis
had the audacity to fly these migrants
to martha's vineyard the liberal safe
haven that it is with another rumored
upcoming flight to delaware near joe
biden's beach house i think that's a
great idea now attorneys in boston
they're now attempting to file a class
action lawsuit against desantis i say
that's great because then every state
can turn around and sue joe biden kamala
harris and his administration for number
one shredding the constitution not
enforcing the laws in the land aiding
and abetting law breaking and by the way
being involved in human trafficking and
he's done this now for the last year and
a half but no one on the left is saying
a single thing about the bodies that are
stacking up at funeral homes in south
texas there's no legal action against
the biden administration
for the hundreds of migrants sleeping on
the streets of el paso there's no
outrage over the dozens of early morning
flights
dispersing illegal immigrants by the
biden administration none whatsoever and
now by the way two million border
crossings and counting but borders are
your vice president kamala harris can't
even be bothered to talk about the
crisis today she was deeply engulfed in
yet another word salad as tucker was
pointing out this time about community
banks in communities where communities
have people in communities take a look
we invested an additional 12 billion
dollars into community banks because we
know community banks are in the
community and understand the needs and
desires of that community as well as the
talent and capacity of community
i didn't know community banks were
inside communities here's one other
example of the signific significance of
the passage of time we could literally
play this all night because this is a
speaking pattern she's developed
everyone can see that vice president
harris is absolutely not up to this job
and i thought joe was bad take a look at
this we are expanding access to
transportation
seems like maybe it's a small issue it's
a big issue you need to get to go and
need to be able to get where you need to
go to do the work and get home the
significance of the passage of time
right the significance of the passage of
time
so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time more parents are seeing the value
of educators when they had to bring kids
and say we're not paying them nearly
enough
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
when we talk about our children i know
for this group we all believe that when
we talk about the children of the
community
they are a children of the community
children of the community you got to go
to get to where you got to go and the
passage of time and community banks have
banks that are in the community so the
people in the community can go to the
community bank it's pretty clear that
neither biden nor harris are willing or
able to secure the border save lives
there's only one way to hold them
accountable this reminder in 49 days you
have all the power to vote hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else